do you find you think more geometrically
or algebraically or you think in words
or are you thinking concepts
uh i i tried to wonder about that and
it's amazingly difficult to actually
figure out what's going on in your own
brain
um um it's
it's something that's very difficult to
describe i seem to have sort of
some sort of algorithms built into my
brain and i sort of know how they're
going to work
and i just don't know how to describe
this i mean
there's a bit of geometric
um imagination going on in there
and there's a bit of algebraic
manipulation but i don't know how the
algebraic manipulation works because i'm
doing things with formulas that are
far too complicated for me to actually
visualize i mean i i can't visualize the
formula itself in my mind but somehow
i still know what it's doing and i've no
idea how this works
actually the the mathematician jacques
adama once
wrote to a lot of mathematicians asking
them to describe how they
thought um and i the problem is it's so
long ago since i looked at this that i
can't remember what he
what conclusions he came to but um there
have been some attempts by
mathematicians to research this question
i was reading penrose's emperor's new
mind
and for anybody who is a mathematician
or physicist
that wants to read that book just read
the last third it was a slug
to get through it was quite an ordeal to
get through the first
bit because it's so much retreading of
similar ground and the last third is
actually where it's interesting but in
the last third he talks about
when he was in high school he's noticed
that he thought differently than his
peers
and then when he got to university he
thought okay great i'll be around other
mathematicians and physicists so we'll
think alike
but then he found that there's even more
a diversity in the in terms of how
people think
what i'm wondering is have you
encountered that
yeah i i noticed this too that that has
sort of gradually dawned on me that lots
of people learn or think in completely
different ways i mean
one example is lectures i mean i i've
always found lectures
if i go to a lecture i fall asleep after
10 minutes i just can't stay awake and i
do all my learning from books and
i sort of assumed everyone was like this
but no an awful lot of people do most
their learning from lectures and just
hardly open the textbook so there are
very different styles
and again some people obviously have
very powerful geometric intuition
and other people have some sort of very
good intuition about something abstract
like set theory and a very little
geometric intuition and so on